all right you guys know over again
because we are rude
hooray didn't like one time you didn't
do that one time one yeah I was awkward
how awkwardly work yeah we needed to
offer it up a little what is that mean
we need to introduce our guest Jason I'm
Gabe these are our best friends these
are our official best friend she gave us
their best we did I did a jig and
they're here to join us to talk about
the Jenna Jillian things amongst other
things this episode of the Jenna Jillian
podcast is brought to you by Squarespace
you guys know what the [ __ ] Squarespace
is Squarespace is the best way to create
a website for yourself whether it's an
online blog shop store website for your
company whatever it is check out
Squarespace because they have some of
the best templates customer service and
honestly just best looking websites go
to Squarespace calm and get 10% off your
website if you enter a product code JJ
this podcast is also brought to you by
texture texture is a what it's a brand
new sponsor and it's a well yeah new
sponsor texture is this great app it's a
it's a website but it's also an app they
have an app it's basically hundreds of
different magazine subscriptions right
at your fingertips so you have to worry
about you know looking for certain
things online or getting physical
magazines you can get it all on texture
like I said they have a hundred over
hundreds of choices free magazine
airplane uh like men's fitness like that
exactly like you literally and you can
save it for offline viewing
really great stuff I'll talk more about
it later but you get free trial at
texture coms last channel Julien thank
you texture we're in the podcast yes
Squarespace alright so anyways well
Jason again
yes yeah thanks for coming yeah we
basically live here so yeah yeah we've
been uh been hanging out quite that
we've been meaning to do this for a
while but we finally have done it yeah
we've been really busy Mario partying
well that's the thing when when you want
to do a podcast with your friends but
you're like really busy friending so
it's hard to like you know before all of
you guys between a Jenna and myself
sometimes
why don't you ever make things or have
Ryan on the podcast that's literally the
reason every time you see Ryan we we
only have like this many days and we're
like we're just gonna have fun and we
never never prioritize doing the podcast
or anything although we really need up I
feel like some day we could have Ryan on
the podcast if we move to Las Vegas he's
pushing for I know he wants us to Vegas
oh we have to go with you all the way to
Las Vegas all right well no go what do
you mean anyways we met Jason and gabs
recently um you guys are really awesome
um dad sings and Jason porpoise Orcs
online if you want to stock his porpoise
star
yeah would you care no I'm saying use to
calling it porpoise story yeah I'd like
to make you words up so so periscope is
porpoise dork
yeah and what's snaps or chops so fat
chops this
yes mark job stop he is aware of
everything not I call it snips youth
education and Pariwar parable Pariwar
you know what is everything that's when
we like are in the war of secretly
periscoping each other yeah it's his
free time
yeah war is yeah Jason is a
jack-of-all-trades a master at periscope
in gaming yeah gaming
for those of you there's uh my video
true life I'm addicted to the elders
that was a true story in that true sorry
and it features both of them in it uh
and it was very appropriate and
important to me that I got Jason in that
video because he's the actual fault he's
the actual person that got me addicted
to the elder scrolls and I'm not sorry
about it either
I'm sorry who are you
is good but yeah right though you guys
like sit online and play destiny ologist
till like 3:00 in the morning I like on
a headset and looking for each other
oh you're handsome gaps if I could just
get you on Elder Scrolls then we could
have a perfect like I think we might
like warp into another dimension from
happiness that happens true guys I
already started playing Mario Party and
you see how angry it makes me I don't
know much more jabs is really
competitive and it's very competitive
and I lose angry you're not the best
admirer from re-punch game is greater in
mid 80s games you're you're not the best
but I will say what I will say is that
you have an incredible voice gabs is a
great singer we have worked together on
just a couple things where she's wanted
to sing a song so I basically propped
the camera up and she's like let out
angelic sounds you did more than prop
the camera propped it up like twice yes
things up you have a YouTube channel
where you put your covers and amongst
other stuff but um how in the world did
you get into singing I feel like this is
different for every single artist we
talked to because it's like did you sing
it like a really young age er yeah I
think I was born that way I think I
probably came out singing a Celine Dion
song like it's a singer literally I
can't remember a time in my life that I
didn't sing um and then yeah I don't
know it was just you take formal
training like with voices yeah yeah I've
been taking voice muscle since I was 10
and I went to college for musical
theatre although that's not the type of
singing I do anymore but um yeah I don't
know my family I was always like people
who were really good at at a lot of
things and I was not that person until I
found singing and I was like okay well I
can sing I'm glad you're all doctors and
everything but can you sing that's what
you got to do
saving lives but like I just covered
this song oh my god and you sing in
addition to YouTube you do certain gigs
where you see with bands at weddings and
stuff like that right oh yeah that's so
cool that is really cool yeah this is an
actual real-life wedding she's like
she's always a singer doll wedding yeah
like they made a movie about me that's
about me Hey what oh yeah
go what it's called the wedding planner
well it's starring Jessica lassika like
Julia gulia and Adam from lumber Sandler
and Julia Mexica Julia Adam Sandler's
hair that movie let me tell you my goal
for everything I'll ever do I want to
get like a perm and have it look like
that that's it that's Gaza's life though
this games is like getting a perm
awesome yes yes which and you are you're
failing right now because you don't have
one today
get on it me tomorrow shaken up shake
things up
and you go okay so you guys have a
really okay so a long time ago I feel
like Jenna and I have discussed how we
met and when we were talking to them on
like our first love really getting to
know each other time really how'd you
guys meet and they were like whoa oblong
we're like what the [ __ ] that's how we
met you guys explain how you guys met um
I was just inspired under what yes yes
you guys literally the first time for
Julia and I had a conversation where
like saheiji me Jenna and how Jamie
Jason we was like bartender what like
that never has been yeah so make sure
just like the copy stories yeah yeah we
moved in together to save on rent has a
raise and your head deep in his line
so yeah he's got going to do go with it
oh my god
but just so you know I chased her for a
little while like it wasn't it wasn't
all easy like showed up at a bar and it
was done in Jason spit [ __ ] he just
dropped his mixtape oh yeah look at this
I actually did make her a mix at one
point ahead oh my god they're straight
but yeah that's your song though right
he made it on that tape that's where you
guys saw I don't think it was on all
night at the bar some blow yeah
something like that
how long ago was that we've been dating
for four years now so we was a song
stitches went back and forth for years
no way was Shawn Mendes wrote stitches
that was baby yeah how does it naturally
no Lilian don't do it there's a fly in
here and joins us don't do it [ __ ]
nemesis why are there flies in here we
had a fly in here in time and I spent
like maybe a third of the podcast just
stand out tricks and I murdered him
twice he was a zombie fly oh [ __ ] um
yeah so that's we're [ __ ] adorable
though that you guys have been together
for four years
congratulations and Counting we've been
friends for six years because we were
friends for two years before I started
so two years of chasing yeah you call it
friends I call friends two years of
friendship Jason lives in a different
way Jason calls it waiting for my
mixtape - yes exactly exactly
yo just wait till Gabe's get that
mixtape man she gonna she gonna fall
from me okay no I'm pacing solid I'm
really great doing horribly inaccurate
impressions of people oh yeah you want
to imitate Jason's mom again who you've
never met yeah look one time we were
hanging out I was like please
introducing what's your mom's name cuz
Loreen they go oh yeah it's me Lorraine
just wondering how all you kids are
doing over there okay uh all right I'll
talk to you a vibrates me Lorraine bye
she sounds like nothing like I feel like
yeah it started this character now I'm
on here Sam here my my fake model our
house yeah
just a big bubble on but she calls and
you're like you're not my mom sweet
Lorraine shake things up shake things
off it's me all right we should have a
calendar of how many times they shake
things up this podcast that's like what
we say this this month yeah this month
it's gonna fade away in a month probably
trail what I think is very interesting
about JJ I call him J train oh yes yes
for you that's stuck cuz yes yes you're
even J train on my phone and then
there's a train emojis yes you're J
train don't get men away you seriously
about periscope I've always found this
very fascinating when people periscope I
feel like a lot of the times the people
who are periscoping are a of pretty
solid Fame or you know status and they
have huge followings be promoting
something and I feel like you have these
awesome like family periscopes with the
same group of a solid amount of people
pretty regularly like you do you know
Friday night turn ups every Friday cares
go up and then you hey what day is it
it's Thursday - okay we're at your gage
of the week is that is an intern an
intern I find it really cool that you
you are you know you you're on time with
these periscopes you treat it seriously
and it I feel like it it kind of sheds
light on what periscope can be because a
lot of periscope is not like that a lot
of periscope is kind of annoying well
when was the first time impaired scoped
huh do you remember when did it come
back remember when it just came out
though yeah we were at home and he was
playing you're playing your 3ds and all
of a sudden he just started talking and
I looked it up we're talking - what are
you doing and but he had his phone faced
towards his 30s so he was just playing a
game and it wasn't his face at all he
was just talking and then I hear him and
he's like talking to our Twitter friends
that we talked to all the time and I
said I'm so confused as to what's
happening right now and I went over and
looked and he was like I don't know it's
this like live streaming thing I don't
know I'm just talking yeah that was the
first time you know
to a point where you know I stopped
playing games on because it was just
annoying to try to sit it up and
everything but you really doing a mini
twitch like yeah you know kind of in a
way screaming yeah do yes but it's very
hard to because D s Union capture card
yeah that's just a whole complicated
thing but in getting other podcast about
capture cards there you go
so it it evolved into so my commute from
work was about an hour each way and I
figured why not just start doing these
in the car
so because I have an hour to just you
know and I mean I can't really talk to
people as much I can't interact as much
because I do have to drive probably not
the safest thing but but you don't like
that like while you're like one wonder
in traffic so you're stopped a lot too
you have so many red lights and like
even everyone knows like that the people
who are on my porpoise dorks a lot they
know that I'll say red light red light
and everyone start commenting yeah you
know that's so cool though like that
kind of stuff where it's very like a
community type yeah I have some lots of
fun people on there and is there a
periscope
like when we periscope sometimes there's
some weird [ __ ] the comment you guys are
[ __ ] weird
well yeah whenever you're doing
something regularly you start to find
the same people are there yes and you
start to make like you guys like the
podcast right it's different than
someone maybe that tweets at you a lot
is different than maybe someone you know
periscope in and of itself there's
people that [ __ ] hang out on there
because they want to watch nice to do
that to you used to like browse
periscope to see who's like I still do
that I'm a creep show what people are
really you they can see when you join
they're like oh jenna Marbles is here
yes not her that's [ __ ] fake no I
mean you do it it's really funny
I don't care there's four people here I
want to see what you're doing because
I'm creeping um I just think it's cool
when you periscope that you're actually
doing something or like talking to them
because I hate when people periscope and
then they just they're like and then
they just stare it like the conduit like
do something
[ __ ] man likely show me something or
talk to me or anything
like I like that
you periscope you do it falls out like
you bring something yeah I wanted to I
don't want people to jump on and see me
walk now there are those like when I was
like commuting to work really early um
those drives would be like I would
definitely be like quieter but you know
at least turn on music to a lawyer yeah
oh yeah some of those drives either an
hour and like at some point I'm just
like I'm surprised there's at least 15
people here that stay here for an hour
like you guys are awesome that's really
cool it's like a way to get intimate
with the Internet in a way that you
never knew you could like when we will
be initially started podcast we used to
stream it on Ustream that's why we
started the pilot yeah well I mean but
before the podcast was a thing we were
on Ustream late at night and we're
having kinda can have conversations like
yeah drinking having fun talking and
people would constantly say you know
start podcasts we did and wow we podcast
we had a you stream on and the podcast
but goes on for a little while and there
was always the core just small group of
people same like we knew him by name we
still do you know it's very cool it's
it's a way that you get intimate on you
know on a level with these strangers
what's the best part of the internet
that you you're connecting with people
they're just genuinely [ __ ] curious
and want to hang you know it's literally
what I do like and and that's the thing
I really like the interaction like I can
actually talk to them right now rather
than like you know get to them later
like like you're talking to me right now
I'm editing nothing because I can't edit
which we were periscoping
and you said that and I was like that's
that's such a good point like you like
it not only does it take like an
entertainment factor to be able to
entertainment blog but but you have to
understand that you can't edit yourself
right like whatever you are in real life
is what you're going to give them and I
feel like a lot of people get scared by
that one parent I'm sure a lot of people
wouldn't want to be live because they're
like I don't know how to not edit myself
but in like it in your and you'll notice
any time I do a periscope I'll never
delete my you guys cuz it you can watch
it for 24 hours afterwards I'll never
delete it because I know I got nothing
that looks like
a tree oh my clapping for myself no
Julia Brian he get started that joke
yeah what's them one time anyone starts
chanting something you just slowly
everyone turns it into Julian yeah you
guys aren't there
shut off the rhpc for that one OHP see
um okay I know that we have guests on
the podcast and you know we're supposed
to 100% focus on them but I want to talk
to you for a sec because you have a
pretty big day coming up next week which
i think is really exciting what you guys
aren't watching this we are going to be
at Madame Tussauds New York watching a
identical wax figure of jenna be
revealed like yeah okay so I'm not gonna
sit here like interview you or do
anything for me I just want thanks dude
I really want you to just kind of talk
about like how you feel because I know
it's like an overwhelming thing yeah
gerrate but I mean like yeah I'm totally
nervous I was nervous for that fitting
they do like it took us what four hours
or something to go through this fitting
and it was like the blue five hours
yeah it was like the most intimate thing
ever like they really measure every part
of your body that you don't want to get
measured like I just remember so like
we've talked about this before but like
parts of the inside of my teeth are like
fake but they've been there for like
over a decade yes and so they're like
it's just a lot of like feeling
embarrassed over and over again like so
they're holding up these like little two
things out to my teeth me like all right
clay 125 for this one whatever the [ __ ]
that means and then they hold it up to
the next ones and when I write one 6064
for those I'm like [ __ ] [ __ ] that's
alright to be out of energy I should fix
them a long time ago I know they're
different colors like on land like just
over and over again like different parts
of your body being late all right so
that's that and I'm like yeah drink it
up [ __ ] it's just like super intimate
and embarrassing go on but overall like
they're amazing they're really sweet and
nice they were yeah they were really
yeah and they do that all the time with
like everyone yeah
so I was like so like do it wasn't the
offside now like put nicer stuff they
were like yeah she's really nice and
like course she is it was Nicki Minaj
nice when she was bent over but yeah
after that you know after the initial
everything sinking I'm I'm just like I'm
nervous
yeah I'm really nervous to see it I'm
really nervous to be there it just feels
like a lot of pressure to let go and be
in wax but it's done now so I'm gonna go
hug her but I can't really describe the
feeling cuz it's just not like a human
thing yeah how can you literally it not
him how can you possibly be prepared for
something like that well my mom's gonna
be there like that we're gonna have
friends there be a lot of people there
you know it's it's it's very exciting
and nerve-wracking I don't know how else
to describe I just feel like the figure
itself with a literal figure and the
lower idea that you are going to have a
pawn in wax is is pretty like terrifying
and interesting and wild in and of
itself but the fact that it's Madame
Tussauds
I know I just you know yeah it's like I
don't know it's it's why you're watching
this right now we will literally be
doing that because this morning we'll be
in New York on blood I'm excited I've
seen pictures of her and - yes you guys
didn't fit she's actually much prettier
than me no she's not but they like like
they did like me touching the wax yeah
they like they did me some favors you
know like there's like yeah a couple
scars like in places that I'm like oh
yeah no it looks it looks really way
ahead for those curious that look nice
measuring process I did wrong it and I
will be barred in the reveal so yeah
it's on Julian's Channel you put that
all together yeah her measuring it was a
crazy experience I put it all on vlog
and I expect the reveal to be just as
cool yeah um but anyway enough leaving
our guests out yeah it's not - I like
this I'm so excited it's scary it's very
like honey
I can just go up to me and be like oh
that's what she looks like Oh bye we
don't know the internet we'll just be
like okay who's this pretty girl like
who is she why she and works like was
she famous for me hug yeah why is her
hero fat purple haired girl and why
she's so well dressed in tan what is
going on
she's so tan it was team wax be a
different type of wax they shifted it
the coolest part is that it's one of the
first selfie taking figures so you can
actually walk up to it and take a selfie
with it I'm gonna take so many selfies
with it yeah and then it she Janna am I
even talking about myself Wow how
pretend you're talking about yourself um
you can I guess she's gonna have like
her own social media account that you
can like follow so I'm like like I don't
want to troll her a little bit just like
yo sup Jenna how you doing I'm a living
girl you gonna change that outfit if you
wear that every day yeah have you guys
been to a Madame Tussauds before I've
been to the one in Vegas I haven't been
in New York but I love it anyone I drove
by in Los Angeles Hollywood won like a
hundred times
yeah I thought I went to make it's like
a million years ago but yeah we'll be
there next month so we're definitely
gonna go hug you let's go yell at you
with Jenna Jenna Jenna are you not
instead wanna play to 1000 or 1 yes
Jenna what was what was it
you've been in Hollywood I've had
friends come visit LA and that's a
touristy they wanna go to that one and
you in today what was it like in Vegas
was it like big was it crowded it was
not crowded this was forever ago this I
think I was like in middle school so you
know like yesterday um it was not
crowded and I'd be alive pictures from
it and I remember like going to take
pictures with like Barbra Streisand
and Celine Dion like that the quality of
like the figures though did it like
freaky ala better some of them did some
like I remember thinking Barbara did not
look like Barbara I feel like they've
gotten really really good yeah it may be
something terrifying yeah well then in
the picture you like it's you um but yet
know for sure they've stepped up the
technology in terms of sculpting it and
stuff like that but it I just think it's
really [ __ ] cool because I've been to
dial a one it's just cool to go and like
yeah see how tall they are or like how
big they are like you just want to stand
next to him you know yeah because even
if you saw Celine Dion in concert and
like yeah but I want to like stand next
to you and like smell your hair and so
so you dig just do that that's why it's
cool so it doesn't it like as a someone
that goes there it yeah some of them
don't look exactly like the person but
it doesn't take away from the experience
of feeling like you're saying nice yeah
you know without all the nervous
pressure if you like hey uh hi I know
they said okay it's interesting how they
their process of selecting these people
to be wax figures it's kind of almost
like how you can select certain articles
when you use texture you have the
ability to cherry pick Sephora for that
Segway German architecture if you want
to find articles about a subject you can
search across many different magazines
just to find that subject and grab
articles take it offline viewing take it
for your plane rides your car rides
except don't read if you're driving but
if your life is driving or your friend
is driving just just read it or on the
train on a commute whatever texture is
your way to read magazines at your
fingertips it's it's a really awesome
service
I feel like magazines are one of the
most outdated ways like you go to
Pandora or Spotify for your music now
this is the way to get your magazines
it's right here on your smartphone on
the app whatever it is check out texture
for some of the coolest ways to read a
magazine because I know you guys don't
get magazine subscriptions more like
come on I still buy game guides
no I don't
knives and subscriptions I ever get are
like my dentists I steal them don't
steal your dentist magazines go to
texture comm slash Jenna Julian for your
free trial they want to give you a free
trial I like the woods in like in like
nail salons and stuff are always like
four years old they just leave it on the
table I know you never know is that yeah
like I think I picked one up last week
that was like gen France and I'm Brad
Pitt are divorcing like no guys you can
resort a new magazine McCarrick guys
will or people might not know that oh if
people might be operated creating their
website on Squarespace right now but you
can do the ease of 24-hour customer
support on chat you go to Squarespace
calm right now to create a website for
yourself and you're like oh [ __ ] I don't
know what this part is damn it's 4 a.m.
let's get on customer chat and they will
help you any time
Squarespace is one of the cleanest
looking templates for any website out
there and it's for the everyday person
it's not just for the people who really
know how to code and all this stuff
Squarespace is for you so check out
Squarespace for your website needs
squarespace.com and enter jayjay at
checkout for a whole ten percent off
your website which adds up trail it adds
up so check them out thank you to our
sponsor yeah thank you guys for
sponsoring us and supporting us um but
yeah like Jason gabs back to you yeah
they're gross they're holding hands are
now like that I can see
um I'm so glad that we found you guys
because we've become really close over
the last couple months right yeah we
talked about it every time we leave your
house yeah thanks you guys I think the
way you say it first was you're very are
speed that's again typical as an adult
to find other adults people on the same
page as you
it's true you know I all I want to do is
hang out Julian for the most part all
you guys want to do is hang out with
each other yeah so it's nice that you
find someone else to do that with but
like you know we're all on the same page
of life for the most part yeah it's not
like I don't know I don't even know no
no absolutely absolutely I you you feel
like I don't know there are certain
times when you meet friends or you try
to meet friends and as much as you enjoy
the person or you enjoy interacting with
them when it comes to like you said the
page on that they are in life like that
matters and so when you're on a similar
page I feel like you know it's very easy
to just link up at any moment in time
and you guys have friends back in New
York they're from New York luck me but
you guys are from New Jersey original
from Philly originally originally met in
New York and then we moved to LA yeah
how's the house with switch been for you
guys how long has it been though it's
been two years um I think it really took
a whole year did a lecture be even
comfortable in LA it was just such how
did you say this is yeah it releases me
a little more than a year yeah yeah
probably I mean it was just such a big
transition and everything about it was
so different than the East Coast yeah
like everything I'm like we had a really
close-knit group of friends I mean you
know we missed them everyday like we
were stolen like on a group text with
them and I know they group text without
us they do they have one without us now
it is so sad but like you know and and
you know like it's hard like you know I
lived with my two best friends for three
years well one of my best friends for
four years and then the other one like
for like another few years but like
that's the thing in New York like you're
constantly surrounded by your friends
like either you live with them they're
probably
on the same block as you or around the
corner like can you walk everywhere
where you want good some same bar yeah
like you see them every day so la was so
different for so long because first of
all you have to drive I know when ever
wants to do that
so people like don't get together as
often um except with you guys I can't
say that anymore because now I see you
every day but no in New York like a year
ago right what's the class summer yet
together in November for playlist and I
don't know the weather here so
disorienting I have yeah I really don't
is it winter
well I'm no idea it's not a total four
degrees I don't know what it's supposed
to be but I'm hot um weird
what anyways I was getting it is that
you're any we're in New York for like a
week yeah and in that week you get used
to wanting to do something so you just
go out and do it you just go walk you
meet someone you go and go drink and
that's you're right it's like a very
giant change from there to here and
Jenna and I have talked about this kind
of countless times on the podcast the
people you meet here just just different
yes jazz different and very different a
lot of times you feel like there are
motives that people have here that
you're not used to seeing in people you
know it's very true I didn't it's weird
to like I mean we both came here because
everyone even wore like said like you
know it's hard to trust people over in
LA and I'm like well whatever like we
have enough friends here we don't even
make any more friends absolutely yeah we
didn't have friends and then I was like
all right we should probably branch out
now I met you guys so weird I know but
we're good
and we met because you are on a singing
competition way back in the day with
Josh Internet reality TV right yes
full circle circle your methods are
Collina Josh we actually an all-night
affair window to their weddings
it was like we caught the bouquet like
oh we all grabbed it and then things
which is very judgmental I had I had to
get up early the next day for work and
leave the hotel and we were coming home
right II like I was like unless in my
mode of just like okay it's time to
knock out we walk through what we're
walking back to the hotel and there's
Jenna and Julian standing out there like
you guys want to go to a bar with Jason
in the mind he is like okay I gotta work
tomorrow we need some sleep
they said do you want to go to a bar bar
hit you know hit my brain and I'm like
yes like we are now you're like that no
other responsibility needs so much fun I
got called I just this my favorite or a
star in the pocket justice I don't I
think I blogged it let's talk about
anybody want to tell it oh my god I
don't know it was so funny
so we're all hanging out and drinking
and whatever and then we're waiting for
food way too long for my like 45 minutes
for anomaly interject here okay this is
a place we were in Santa Barbara I don't
remember the [ __ ] Street but it was
like the street with old bars yeah and
it's drinking time it's like 1:00 a.m.
1:30 close to 2:00 when the bars are
starting to kick you out and we're like
we're [ __ ] hungry we're drunk hungry
we want some tacos so we go to this
place it's like a streetside Shack like
yeah they're supposed to [ __ ] without
tacos for your drunk-ass all goddamn
night if you're open Natalie yeah beside
you're there for my license lamb yeah
she look at me in the morning we [ __ ]
ordered and these guys literally took 50
minutes to give us like a collective
seven top not delivery just no way Danny
a designer watch Willie and I are hangry
like about to burn this place now from
your hangry it's so drunk
yeah continues so we're standing up
start with these tacos and this guy
comes up to us and looks at Jenna and
realizes that she's someone that he
recognizes
but can't put his finger on exactly how
he knows who she is or who the hell she
is and he looks at her he goes I know
you and she's like cool you know being
Jenna and she's like great yeah cool
nice to meet you um and he goes you're
you're I justice and we all start dying
because of course he means iJustine
which is religion again all accounts but
he was so sure enough like he's just
like many objects dying and we're like
no no she's not
I just Dean no that's I know who she is
and like Julie and I are both like dude
like keep going you're on the right
track like YouTube
you know just you're getting there but
like no you're you were more encouraging
than I are you like mad laughing yeah
it's [ __ ] guy who's like are you sure
you're not I just said I promise you I'm
not lying to you I'm not a person but no
but you were like even nicer than that
because you're like I would love to be
like I watch apparently did wrong wrong
it was like green at that point you're
senior me I thought the word I just
assumed we were all crimes I was such a
fan of I just see you she's really like
honored that he's working yeah yeah I
yeah she's the researcher of YouTube so
I was like okay you're like thank you
just know I'm not one of the best things
I've ever heard
yeah but then like I didn't know your I
just sorry yeah it got better because he
pulled me aside and goes no no but for
real that's I justice I don't know like
I think it's not first of all there is
no I justice and second of all no and
I'm not gonna tell you who she is so
then he goes alright whatever whatever
do you think she'd take a picture with
me and I was like yes she would because
she's the coolest person ever but like
you have to know who she is and he was
like no no I got it so he goes and takes
a selfie with Jenna we have do you watch
and know this Instagram we watch him
posted to Instagram and tag I justice
and we all just lose our shirt
and it was the best moment I just really
want to know like his friends the next
day when they saw that big like you're
an idiot hope it's still up somewhere
can you like can you guys look let me
know or if you are that person if you
lie that is just on YouTube looking for
I justice you can cure the person drunk
guy that lives in Santa Barbra it just
sounds like a superhero I just said it
does should we use this tech did we
decide the I justice we're just gonna
like carry a bunch of mo fees in the
backpack just uh be in charge and
everyone even that one I just this okay
uh no no that's that's a better name no
but they should also just I was no fee
man other things like someone steals my
do something I just I just the would
work
I just should be human I don't miss you
be alright tell me well I just should
just be the superhero manifestation of
uh like Find My iPhone she like flies
around like picking up iPhones and
returning them but maybe if I'm her
chest is like that radar like this I was
when he said it to me I was like it hits
me and my giggle big so I just says oh
man if you guys want to follow us on
Twitter she's twitter.com slash I just
the realize I didn't know they just got
verified so official I just said and
then that [ __ ] guy came back like 10
minutes later yeah figured on she wasn't
I I stepped in I was like bye no Julian
goes you bloody blue yeah yeah you can
literally don't straight at you every
way you could have blown goodbye like
you were so mad and you were so honored
but then randomly this couple was
fighting behind us remember that
you won't even get it that was [ __ ]
ridiculous
Anna's drink helps didn't know what
happened with this girl help this girl
needed help okay and you and I went over
her she was like stumbling around drunk
so we were we went over to her we were
like hey are you okay like can we get
you a cab like all this [ __ ] she was
like no new me my friends like literally
every drunk girl ever and so we were
right fine she was being kind of like
nasty so we went back and this guy comes
up to me he was like yo dude like why
you talking to my girl like your girl
almost just fell into traffic I was like
yeah you heard me saying yeah you shut
up like get out of here your girls away
from falling into the street and sleepy
now he's waiting for his goddamn tacos
to me
we all just want tacos everyone relax
other than that though that was great it
was a great night she's great nice holy
[ __ ] can it say I fell in love true what
a story though that's vanilla rate
amongst people who couldn't handle their
alcohol yeah we Italian shots of
fireball we were deep lots of shouting
yeah I remember - Jenna was thanks good
- out you're welcome I don't think any
amount of alcohol would make me clear it
does Emily and I call it young pretty I
think we called her that for like a week
ago
great [ __ ] name I just said she
changed your Twitter name that I just
it's not the handle just your nature why
has no one named I just aside found out
you can change their name Tyler and they
got real excited I didn't have in real
yes yeah any time any time you want I
can just change your name on Twitter so
the first night like I figured it out
probably two minutes later I named
myself numbers because I'm not a name on
number changes name two numbers and then
he tweeted one two three four five and
it was like 5:00 in the morning or
something cuz I think we just got moved
ABS would not fall asleep
thank you didn't go to sleep until you
change it back to me she literally like
Jason change it back and I'm like no no
Jason change it back change it back like
that buddy so that was the next day I
decide
our Sunday numbers yeah I decided the
gaps guys so yes yes the next day
here's like oh I just remembered again
that you can change your name and I was
like Jason it's your name like once we
remember gamers and he changed it to my
name Deb's she chanted cats gaps here
yeah yeah I just I just wish though
Twitter I hope you're listening
I just wish mr. mrs. Twitter please
watch it when it when I tweet with my
different name leave it at that name
until I switch names again because
numbers doesn't make sense now my 1 2 3
4 does it make sense with it made by me
when my name was nothing with the tweet
yeah yeah link the tweets in the name
mr. and mrs. Twitter please can you be
more Thank You Love Jason's trolling
because I need to make more names no no
it's your name yeah my name is whatever
I want to call your mom she's on my side
freeze well she's right here okay here
yeah abstain Carla gear son is changing
his name me I don't like it well you
know I was never able to control Jason
but you know on Twitter he's got a tweet
1 2 3 4 5
you're like a mom in Boxberger yeah
she's Linda Belcher
yeah Belcher I'm Spanish by a man which
is a man I know oh my god let it show
that's oh do we are we the same person
are you me yeah they're also well also
youth the three of you are hardcore all
this fan oh yeah Jenna gets really upset
I'm like [ __ ] out of it
Oh
I'm just lazy don't like start making
jokes and I'll just sit there like you
guys signaled officer this was a
successful undo is that one time Jenna
made a joke she was like right guys
office right gonna be honest she like
made enough and we're like yeah Jenna
likes the shut up about the mall scene
shut up about the Sun yeah shut up about
the Sun yeah cuz we literally we like
did anyway that is that was like shut up
about the money yeah just watch me yeah
whatever happened we were doing it sort
of like you know we had a relative idea
of what we're gonna say and then like in
true the way that we shoot things form
we're just like one-upping each other
and taking hours to shoot so like it
turned into a very cat it was was we
casual conversation sort of like he's
getting mad at me for needing to buy a
bunch of leggings and then I turned it
into like yeah well like Yuri credit
card like you gotta give it back and
then he just kept yelling enough about
the mall and I just I looked at him
after one of the take something can you
like get rid of that one like that one
doesn't work like what you say like do I
need this no you understand this is from
the office and then he takes 10 minutes
to explain the scene to me I'm like I
haven't seen it I don't get it whatever
but then I did watch it and it is
[ __ ] sterile screen so I am like
classic game yeah yeah that I let you
keep enough about the mall because you
you stood up to me you're like no no
we're keeping this in here yeah the
three of us quote the office too much
and and Jenna just pretends to
understand while you guys which is very
nice you guys know firsthand you guys
how much I want to call the office all
the time and just get zero validation
then do it anyway enter Jason and Gibbs
yeah they give me that validation
so thank you for that amongst other
things like being our friends and coming
on the podcast thank you for coming on
the podcast is a lot of fun says yeah
gab sings like an angel are you going
you're going on doing a couple of shows
with Josh yeah we are going to link gabs
his channel Jason's Twitter periscope
everything below so make sure to check
them out
Gaza is great boys great seeing great
covers I have great names I know the
ones you chose um November 30th in
Philadelphia and uh nope December first
and second and it or take it still on
sale yes they are
I don't know if it's sold out yet okay
um we can find the links is that but she
will be singing at Josh's live show so
yeah a song I wrote and she said in
Brighton she said both my live shows
that was awesome that was actually some
of our first times I've really had yeah
that was when we became friends and it's
so fun me and Brett were up in the
balcony like looking God's shoes the
first thing Jenna ever said to me was I
like your shoes and I was like great
friends they were sick they runs you're
really sitting handprint and a lot of
our describes out now is just like I
wish we were friends then I know because
I would have been at the Arizona show if
I remember it there's so many times were
like oh we should have been friends like
five ear sculpt cuz we drove like we all
could've driven together
oh just describe the shoes please you
know I don't even honestly remember what
they look like now I just remember they
were like ankle boots are like something
like that they were just 30 black like
black booties peep toe yeah there you go
yeah
hangs up machine I don't know what any
of those words be Jason is also a shoe
reviewer that's true though you do
reviews on yeah you guys that's actually
mean that I do not even mean
he's actually a review shoes yeah but
not those shoes not be really fun I
think you had this sneakers like the New
Balance sneakers that you were testing
out and you reviewed them like they're
cute they're black shoes different but
thank you so much for joining us this is
a lot of funny men check their stuff out
yeah check things up check yourself and
we'll remember this podcast we're just
going to continue doing this just
nothing like in cameras yeah yeah it's
getting hot in here yeah it is really I
wasn't sure is this a normal thing gets
hot me yes your turn old era you know we
have to throw the air because the sound
will get picked up by these knives yeah
which is unfortunate so we just sit here
and sweat we're still we're still on the
hunt for a completely silent a
completely silent fan which you know
what we can't find the guys right now
but it exists somewhere on the internet
and so could you with Squarespace so
check out Squarespace please because
they have the best way to make website
I'm Tony you're going to be surprised at
how easy it is to make a really good
looking website Squarespace commenter
products CRO JJ a check out you could
make a website for I justice if you're
gonna be real life I don't waste your
money long ago make it Twitter don't
waste your mother's address this website
because Jenna's are doing texture comm
slash Jenna Julian for your free trial
of online magazines at your fingertip
hundreds of magazines you can search
them grab what articles you want save
them for offline viewing that's
important because you can save them for
offline viewing texture calm thank you
to our sponsors tester there's so much
regarding and thank you to our guests
our host and thank you to you guys for
watching and hanging out we will see you
guys next week
yeah where you gonna play rockfish yeah
the band back together
[ __ ] beer that's game I mean Oh dad
singing in Jason drumming okay I haven't
if you guys are still here okay if you
still made it through this entire
podcast I know a lot of your dog but do
those of you do I appreciate if you're
still here
leave in the comments what our rock band
name needs to be oh geez podcast I am
this is dynamic can you ship the four of
our names work on it guys yeah that's
somethin comin oh don't be going down
them yeah $30 the three of you are Jays
and I'm a G so that's famiglia goodbye
Jake what about what about Gabi in the
Jays to get out in the Jays oh that's
enough for me thank you guys for
watching that's ten cars next week